have you ever watched tokyo revengers
and been like
are middle schoolers or young kids ever
really this bad
beating the crap out of each other and
like committing serious crimes
or maybe when you experienced akunohana
flowers of evil for the first time and
you thought
like is this even possible for kids to
act like this and have such
dark intent underneath the surface well
imagine all that violence
times 50 and then maybe you've got
giujikanokunin
to preface this video the manga is very
explicit very violent
much more so than the previous anime and
manga i even mentioned
at the beginning of the video so if
you're not into that then this might not
be your cup of tea
there are many points that are
nauseating and pretty gross
but if you want to learn a bit about one
of the most cursed
revenge and torture manga i've ever read
whether that's a good or bad thing
then let's continue down this rabbit
hole
[Music]
now this manga follows the story of
urumah a boy who is bullied by a group
of five demented friends in elementary
school
and demented honestly puts it lightly
they called uttama
human subject one as they beat him to an
extent that
is already pretty dark to start off with
you know choking him etc
but as we progress only through chapter
one it takes a very
drastic turn as shigoku kyo the leader
of this pack of bullies
tells the boys one thing that the most
amazing thing you can do
is kill someone and this really sets the
tone for the manga like
it does glorify killing and tortures so
i truly wouldn't recommend it to anyone
i mean it's entertaining it's not very
long it's only 38 chapters
and at times it does provide insight
into the darkest recesses of human
nature
but to an extent that is probably
distasteful to most
if you've got romance and slice of life
on one side of a spectrum
this is on the entire other side of that
spectrum at the very end
but anyway to return to the story the
leader of the pack shigoku kyo is
really really demented and his torture
of uduma ends up with him
crashing his family's car in a wreck
that kills his parents
and puts his brother into a coma like
full-on massacre
and from here utama decides to take
revenge on all of them and
thus starting the story but before he
can do that his grandfather stops him as
it's obvious at this point that udoma
would either be caught by the police or
killed by kyo since he's just an
elementary schooler
an elementary schooler who's already
mentally determined to kill
five people but still a young kid
nonetheless
and his grandfather a former soldier and
another really messed up dude
teaches uttama over the next three years
about killing people and fighting so
that when he takes revenge
he's ready and i mean no one in this
story is really like a good character
they're all really twisted in one way or
another like
even the female love interest is weirdly
obsessed with uduma and goes to all
these dangerous places that
no sane student would go to but
no one compares to the main six
characters uduma and the five
antagonists
the title of this manga jujikandorokunin
doesn't have a direct english
translation
but with my intermediate knowledge of
japanese jiu-jika refers to the cross
and rokunin means six people so the
title is
down to its bare minimum the six people
of the cross
which might be an ironic play by the
mangaka to contrast the almost demonic
and demented depths to which all these
characters show
or maybe it's a way to show that this is
the absolute
truest human nature with no morals or
anything imprinted on them by society
but regardless this manga is not
horror if that's what you were getting
from this review so far
it's not it's it's basically just a
bunch of torture
like the most famous torture anime i can
think of right now is higurashi when
they cry
but that show is very tastefully done
with mystery
and different storylines and actual
scary horror scenes
but this manga is just all of that
stripped away for a very
dark and explicit story from like
scanning people to what is basically
quartering them it does not hold back
at all granted that's not to say
it's terrible because it is interesting
and the art is
really good it definitely encaptures all
of their facial expressions very well
from scared to intimidating to
whatever this is it is very well suited
to this dark manga
the art isn't smooth or perfect in any
way like berserk or vagabond nowadays
it's very rough and sharp and it just
fits perfectly
it focuses a lot on character's eyes
which you know to go along with the
religious subtext in the title
and the idea that eyes are the window
into someone's soul
it works once again with the insight
into human atrocities that this
manga focuses on even if their eyes are
just
pure black it still tells a story shows
an emotion
or lack of emotion more often than not
just about every frame that the main
character is in he's got this really
unnerving look on his face and there
isn't a moment in this mango when i
didn't feel
like something horrible could happen the
very next panel
and i gotta say it does this very well
because there have been very few times
if ever that manga has made
me uncomfortable or squeamish but this
one did manage to make me grimace a
number of times
i'm not gonna talk about what explicitly
did because
one i don't wanna think about it again
two i don't wanna spoil in case you guys
want to read and three
i'd probably get demonetized the story
is also not necessarily bad udoma has to
deal with a lot of obstacles to find his
former bullies it's not like he's just
going one by one and offing them it's
not
nearly that boring one thing that i
liked was that the number one rule
the rule that his grandfather reminds
him of before he starts this journey
is to make sure that the five bullies
haven't reformed before he does anything
which is one of the very few morally
correct and saving graces of this manga
that the grandfather who i assume from
experience as a former soldier
makes sure that uduma doesn't just go
out and kill people who have changed for
the better
it's a fair idea but we pretty quickly
realized that
none of these kids are good people it
was really just a nice sentiment to
start the story off
and show that uduma isn't just a
mindless killer because it is often said
how
the moment you kill someone you're no
better than the bad guys
but i guess this just kind of went to
morally justify udoma and make us root
for him despite the things he's doing to
his former bullies which are
just as messed up as what they do to
other people
and we also have to deal with things
like school life and police
there are a lot of moments of a rather
intriguing cat and mouse chase
whether it's between udema and the five
bullies or the police or
the love interest who just loves to
insert herself into
everything involving the main character
for some reason
so if you have an hour or two on your
hands and aren't faint of heart
i guess go ahead and give it a looksie
but again it's hard to give my stamp of
approval on this manga
i'm gonna continue with it as it
releases chapters which i suppose is a
testament to it
and it's merit or it might just be that
i don't like to draw manga once i've
caught up
so yeah as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses